New tech.
An old grudge.
And maybe a fan-service cameo to boot.
There's plenty to parse in the trailer for
the third season of "The Mandalorian".
Grogu, apparently, has a brand new bassinet.
While this might seem a little inconsequential
in the grand scheme of things, what's interesting
is that it seems to be that this carriage
comes equipped with a few gadgets.
There's a moment in the trailer in which the
titular Mandalorian, Din Djarin, and Grogu
are moving through what looks like a dark
cave.
A beam of light pops on from the front of
Grogu's crib.
Maybe Peli Motto has kitted out the floating
pod with some adventuring gear, or perhaps
Din's been tinkering with it in his spare
time.
And wouldn't you think there are some other
handy hidden features?
There's also a blink-and-you'll-miss-it shot
of Doctor Pershing and someone else strolling
through some kind of facility.
Fans will remember that he's the scientist
working on the cloning project for the remains
of the Empire.
He was last seen being forced by Djarin and
Cara Dune to help break into Gideon's ship.
Considering the Empire wants to use Grogu
for its experiments, it might not be a good
sign that Pershing is back, but maybe we'll
find out more about what he was up to with
all those dead clones.
"Sadly, the body rejected the blood."
Further into the trailer, there are also some
moody shots of a ruined Mandalorian city.
Bo-Katan Kryze stands in a long hallway that
looks very similar to the throne room on Mandalore
seen in "The Clone Wars."
That said, it also looks a little bit small
to be the exact same location, unless it's
gotten a makeover in the last few decades.
It's not impossible that the shot just makes
it look more cramped, or the throne itself
was moved elsewhere after the Empire purged
the planet.
As for Bo-Katan, it's clear she harbors a
grudge against Din Djarin for a couple of reasons.
For one, calling out that the Children of
the Watch caused a rift among the Mandalorian population.
Then there's the fact that Din won the Darksaber
from Moff Gideon, something Bo-Katan wanted
to do herself so that she could rightfully
take Mandalore's throne.
As Pedro Pascal, who plays Din Djarin, hinted
during an interview with Total Film, Din is
clearly going to become a reluctant leader,
which suggests he might have to fend off an
attack from Bo-Katan.
The trailer shows Din alongside a few other
Mandalorians, each with their own unique helmets
and armor.
Perhaps the reluctant hero will add a few
new members to Clan Mudhorn in Season 3.
The trailer seemingly reveals a surprising
appearance from a fan-favorite "Star Wars"
alien: Babu Frik.
It looks like the tiny Anzellan droidsmith
is back after his scene-stealing debut in
"The Rise of Skywalker."
It's worth pointing out that Frik isn't referred
to by name, so it could easily be another
Anzellan with a talent for fiddling with droids.
The character certainly looks and sounds like
Frik, though.
And wouldn't it be more fun for it to be him?
"Babu Frik, can you help us with this?"
It's not clear whether Shirley Henderson,
who is best known for playing Moaning Myrtle
in the "Harry Potter" films, is reprising
her voice role as Frik, but it's certainly possible.
Who knows?
We might even get to learn more about Frik's
mysterious past.
Henderson told Esquire that she's thought
of a tragic backstory for the little engineer.
"Beyond the film, Babu has lived a life.
Out there is a lost love.
He thinks about her sometimes when he sits
down in his workshop and lets his thoughts
drift away.
That's what I think, anyway."
"The Mandalorian" is set well before the events
of the sequel trilogy, so it's plausible that
Season 3 will reveal more about Babu's life
before he crosses paths with Rey and the gang.
If it's him at all.